[Musique]
vous avez choisi rtl je vous remercie en
simultané également sur m6 avec eux
toute l'équipe je pourrais vous les
présenter un par un mais autant faire un
jingle groupe et pour que vous
compreniez bien à qui vous avez affaire
[Musique]
action qu'une hôtesse et un collectif
d'une centaine de détail en france avec
qui on a eu la bonne idée d'envoyer à
matignon à jean castex une petite
culotte une culotte pour lui dire à ce
monsieur castex que non nous ne sommes
pas non essentiels et que on a tout à
fait le droit d'être ouverte au même
titre que les autres commerce iep
disquaires jardinerie ça nous saoule
on en a gros n'est ce pas la première
chose que nous enfilons le matin pour
nous habiller même vous messieurs les
ministres
qu'est ce que le courrier je trouve ça
inconcevable que qu'en tant que magasin
de lingerie on soit considérée comme non
essentiels on ne comprend pas où a été
fait ce choix on peut aller acheter un
livre et c'est très bien mais par contre
moi j'ai des clientes qui ont besoin de
soutien gorge allaitement qui ont besoin
de soutien gorge grande taille et puis
qui vient de comment on fait eh bien on
peut pas j'ai déjà eu une discussion
avec eux moi ces trois personnes encore
marine un peu moins maintenant marine
c'est un peu moi mais c'est des
personnes que j'aime pas et franchement
je les trouve aussi fausse que mes
fesses et que mes seins cette tenue
c'est mon coup de coeur du moment et je
me sens super à l'aise ultra branchée et
surtout prête pour sortir magnifique le
canapé franchement le gala pays les au
soleil si sa tenue qu'on vous demande de
juger par son canapé
c'est a tenu la wii jeux wii c'est joli
mais je préfère ton canapé mais nous le
début
un troupeau qui se déplacent
régulièrement grâce à son équipe de
gardiens mais même pour un cavalier
expérimentés l'exercice peut vite
tourner au rodéo quand l'animal en a
marre de l'homme il le fait savoir
je fais pas ça se fait pas c'est abusé
si tu veux plutôt bon je te plaît ne
sais pas si ça passe à côté
j'étais bête
foutoir en tout le monde
pour le moment la situation sanitaire
semble se stabiliser au cours des sept
derniers jours en moyenne 32 1978 test
positif à la coke 19 ont été déclarées
chaque jour et depuis quelques jours le
nombre de contaminations n'augmente plus
mais bien sûr il ne faut pas crier
victoire trop vite parce que ce plateau
reste quand même très élevé
vous l'avez l'application ou pas moi je
les par l'agencé anticorruption
alors moi je l'aimais en revanche il
alors jamais où je suis là je n'ai pas
dépensé le bluetooth
finalement je l'aimais sa soeur jeanne
vérifier il allume jamais mais pas de
contacts à risque détecté aujourd'hui
midi l'application seulement est positif
à la bogossitude yann david
l'amertume l'amertume oui marié depuis
combien de temps foule trop c'est comme
ça qu'à jeter
c'est un tournoi entre happy few douze
clubs européens parmi lesquels les
prestigieux real de madrid manchester
united ou encore la juventus de turin
ont décidé de créer leur propre
championnat de football
financé par la banque américaine jp
morgan la super league c'est son nom se
joint entre les clubs les plus riches
de quoi écoeurer certains fans de foot
aux quatre coins de l'europe
les supporters outre et donc mais aussi
des joueurs qui ont pris la parole hier
sur les réseaux en france on peut citer
au psg ander herrera ou bien le
défenseur de l'om alvaro gonzalez qui
font clairement part de leur opposition
au projet car cette nouvelle compétition
sportive et surtout une nouvelle poule
aux oeufs d'or pour les quelques clubs
triés sur le volet l'argent des sponsors
et des droits de retransmission aiguise
déjà toutes les convoitises
l'uefa l'entité qui gère le football
européen et organise la ligue des
champions crient à la concurrence
déloyale et menace de sanctions
eric cantona monte au front contre la
super league n'est pas question de mois
tous deux chalutiers mais de honte honte
que les supporters n'est pas été
consultés sont en forme ces neuf doubles
et trois stades d'un homme ou bien hélas
la mentalité du chameau il s'agenouille
il renonce et le respect la [ __ ] ou bien
ils à l'amantadine une mentalité du lion
il veut tout dévorer ou bien alors il
atteint le stade supérieur de l'enfant
et il retrouve une innocence et un
recommencement continuelle de
l'existence et de la curiosité et de
l'amour de vivre il ya qu'on entend un
enfant fois
mais ça dans une classe je crois qu'on
aime tessa 36 37 37 dans ses followers
c'est non non c'est non je n'ai pas
tremblé
donnez moi c'est sûr chez reed j'ai
trouvé le nom de notre futur enfants
garçons ou filles déjà vu que c'est la
saison numéro 10 et que c'est un numéro
10 comme 6 ou 10 ou 16 août et vous
savez moi je pense que mon fils il peut
devenir quelqu'un
genre si on est un peu dans les livres
et ben il peut s'intéresser de plus en
plus hors poët poët un philosophe un
scientifique un mozart parce qu'on a un
piano et regardez maintenant les images
de cet incroyable sauvetage en inde
filmée par une caméra de sécurité
on y voit un enfant tombé sur les rails
et tenté en vain de remonter sur le quai
quand un employé de la gare surgi en
courant et s'ouvre l'enfant in extremis
du train qui arrivait aucun blessé on
salue le courage et l'héroïsme de cet
employé vous allez devoir être attaché
24 heures ça va c'est drôle ok c'est bon
ça me va le gage est plutôt pas mal être
enchaînés vision 24 heures bain
moi ça me déplaît pas au final alors
attendons mais pour chier toi on aurait
bien discuter un peu plus mais quand on
fatigue leur maître avec toutes nos
questions
jean marc et simone c'est pour nous le
font vite savoir c'est l'histoire du
mouton le plus célèbre du moment sur
internet
coincé dans une tranchée il a eu de la
chance sorti d'affaires par ce jeune
sauveteur
c'est donc tout content qu'il a pu
rejoindre son prêt banon